so yesterday when Donald Trump lied as
we already stated Donald Trump lied
about President Obama calling family
members are not calling family members
that struck a particularly nervous san
antonio spurs coach gregg popovich who
has been outspoken about his opposition
to president trump particularly within
the mannerisms and the way that donald
trump carries himself there's plenty of
video that you can go and check to see
what gregg popovich thinks of donald
trump
but yesterday his words went to a new
level and I think it's appropriate it's
an appropriate level to match the
absurdity of what Donald Trump did
yesterday in his accusations against
previous presidents with regard to the
families of the fallen and there's a
quote that I want to bring up on your
screen it was in an interview in the
nation dot-com Gregg Popovich had this
to say quote this man in the Oval Office
is a soulless coward who thinks that he
can only become large by belittling
others this has of course been a common
practice of his but to do it in this
manner and to lie about how previous
presidents responded to the deaths of
soldiers is as low as it gets we have a
pathological liar in the White House
unfit intellectually emotionally and
psychologically to hold this office and
the whole world noses nose especially
those around him every day the people
who work with this president should be
ashamed because they know better than
anyone else
just how unfit he is and yet they choose
to do nothing about it this is their
shame most of all if I was on my radio
show I would play an applause track
because this is spot on I will talk
about the faux controversy people are
trying to get upset that Gregg Popovich
is speaking in this manner we could
speak about that momentarily but the
substance of what he said I think Gregg
Popovich has struck to the core of the
issue everyone knows that Donald Trump
is unfit to be President of the United
States most of us knew that before the
election but now everyone who's looking
knows and so we have to ask ourselves
this question so what's worse Donald
Trump
or the people who still enable Donald
Trump his supporters his staff people
who are around him who understand the
seriousness of their role in their place
not only in history but in in today
right now they're their jobs today are
so vitally important but yet and still
they say nothing they say nothing about
Donald Trump because they feel like they
have to have some loyalty to serving
Donald Trump took an oath to protect and
defend the United States from the
Constitution against threats domestic
and foreign emphasis on domestic so
Donald Trump is a threat to the United
States he's a threat to the Constitution
of the United States
I mean case in point the entire fiasco
with the NFL listen I'm tired of talking
about NFL players taking the knee but
when you have the President of the
United States who insists that they
cannot do that he is directly
contradicting his oath to defend the
Constitution by violating the
Constitution and infringing on their
First Amendment rights I mean it's very
simple this it's not rocket science and
so while we may not feel like talking
about these issues anymore the President
of the United States is directly
damaging America on many fronts not just
on the culture war issues I mean take a
look at what how he's sabotage the
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson with
regard to North Korea we had the
opportunity to have back-channel
communications with North Korea to stave
off the necessity of any type of armed
conflict and yet and still Donald Trump
the President of the United States took
to Twitter to undermine the Secretary of
State he is undermining the Iranian
nuclear deal and he's putting us in a
dangerous position putting our allies in
dangerous positions and so it's not just
the culture war issues that Donald Trump
is dangerous on it's national security
that he is a problem on he's a problem
across the board but again I asked a
question who's more responsible the
people who are around him who are in
abling him because they want to be loyal
to him or Donald Trump who we all knew
going in was this type of character last
but not least his voters at this point
anyone who could still stand that 38%
the
it showed you earlier in the show anyone
who still falls in that category must be
relegated to the dregs of society and I
know a lot of people are like well you
can't just say this about an entire
swath of voters but if you can actively
look at who Donald Trump is and still
support him if you could look at his
behavior and still condone it if you
could look at his policies or the lack
thereof and still think that he is a
successful president then you are not
qualified to be in the broader
conversation we absolutely must build
coalitions that can push back against
that 38% who are active that 30% who
goes out into vote that 38% who are
dispersed between enough swing states to
actually be a threat so strategically we
have our work cut out for us but
philosophically and morally this group
is so repugnant because they can manage
to stand by Donald Trump still today
despite all of the issues that are with
it but despite the fact if I could use
Gregg Popovich's words that he is a
soulless coward and everybody knows it